IS THERE IS NOT NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY STONE RECOGNISED
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER K. HAN BENNETT. BERMAN
HELLO BLOOM OERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES GEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
LARA MIKE FONG VINCE FONG
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LEVY LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
NGUYEN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TÍNH WILDER AS THE VALLAPUDUA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WILSON. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN. IMAM
YASIR. AND THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL
. LET US PRAY THAT ALL MEMBERS
OF THIS CHAMBER BE GUIDED IN
THEIR THOUGHTS WORDS AND
ACTIONS. TO ACHIEVE THE GREATEST
GOOD FOR ALL. LET THEM HAVE A
HIGH SENSE OF RESPONSIBILITY AND
BE FREE FROM TEMPTATIONS OF
SELFISH INTERESTS. LET THEM BE
FILLED WITH KNOWLEDGE AND WISDOM
SO THAT RESOLUTIONS ADOPTED AND
LAWS ENACTED ME MEET THE
STANDARDS FOR THE GOOD OF OUR
PEOPLE. I MEAN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING TO JOIN US IN THE FLAG
SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEYARTO AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE READY
BEGIN. MY DILIGENCE FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. EACH
OF THE SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE TO THE
ASSEMBLY REDDIT SEVEN AM THE
AUDIBLE KELLY SEYARTO SIXTY
SEVEN JUST RESIDING SHE LOOKS
PROTEST. AND MISS. MISTER FLOOR.
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL WILL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. PARTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE MOVING ON TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES
FOR THE DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MISS
REYES. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
AND MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENSUS TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY SIX AND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA TO ALLOW THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
AB TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT WARD. FOR
THEIR HEARING ON WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY SEVENTH PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE. AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN RAMOS FROM
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE-
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE HOLDEN FROM THE
PUBLIC SFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT VINCE FONG
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
REYES FROM THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE- APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AND AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE BERMAN FROM THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW AB
NINETEEN OH ONE NAZARIAN FROM
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
ORDER THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILE. THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO MODIFY ITS
JURISDICTION AND IT IS NO LONGER
FISCAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER MEMBERS WE
HAVE GUESTS WITH US IN THE
GALLERY TODAY. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY PLEASE
WELCOME STUDENT CONSTITUENTS
SHAUN MARSH NAY. MOVING ON TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE THE
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
208-926-5520 THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR WITH A MEMBER
SEVENTY THIRTY EIGHT WITH A
MEMBER SEVENTY SEVENTY SEVEN OF
THE MEMBERS. NINETEEN TWELVE THE
EMBERS TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
MINUTES TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE
MINUTES TWENTY NINE THIRTY SEVEN
MINUTES TWENTY THIRTY
SETTLEMENTS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
WITH A MINUTES EIGHTEEN FIFTY
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY ONE THIRTY
NINE OF THE MINUTES HOUSE WASN'T
SHOULD WANT TO WANT SOMETHING
NINETEEN. ONE WITH MINISTRY
THREE TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE
AM EST WE FOUR TWENTY MINUTES
TWENTY THIRTY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
SIX MEMBERS FIFTH TO MEMBERS
TWENTY THREE FOR THEM INTO SOME
OF TWENTY FOUR SIX FIVE. ALL
BILL WILL BE DEEMED AND
AMENDMENTS WILL BE A. MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY. RE BY
ITEMS TO. FIVE THREE. NINE SHALL
BE PASSED AND RETAINS. WHEN WE
ON NOW TO FIVE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX SIX TWO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KARA THE CLERK WILL READ
. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
BACK LEADING TO DISCRIMINATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY TWO WOULD CLARIFY. OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
REPRESENTS AN AXE IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST DO YOU HAVE THE AGE THE
STATE'S LARGEST CIVIL RIGHTS
AGENCY WITH A MISSION TO PREVENT
UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION AND
PRACTICES AGAINST CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. SPECIFICALLY DLPH
ENGAGES IN INVESTIGATIONS
INVOLVING COMPLAINTS OF PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE EMPLOYEES AND
INDIVIDUALS WERE VICTIMS OF
SYSTEMIC DISCRIMINATION IN
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AS WELL AS HATE
CRIMES AND TRAFFICKING. IN
RECENT YEARS YET FUTURE SPACE
SOME CHALLENGES IN DISPUTES
REGARDING ISN'T ALREADY AN
ABILITY. HOWEVER AND DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
VERSUS CATHY'S CREATIONS TWENTY
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA COURT OF
APPEALS AFFIRMED THE DFG H. AS
THE AUTHORITY TO ACT IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST SAYS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
BRING CIVIL ACTION THAT PUTS
THEIR ON GOING MISSION. THIS
BILL WOULD SIMPLY REMOVE ANY
AMBIGUITY REGARDING DFT AGES
ABILITY TO PROSECUTE CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC INTEREST RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE.
AND ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS THIRTY ONE
THROUGH THIRTY FOUR SHALL BE
PASSED A NEW CHANGE WE'LL MOVE
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. YOUR RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ACCOLADE IN THE CIVIL LAW. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
REQUIRE VEHICLE HISTORY REPORT
PROVIDERS TO INCLUDE THE NAME
MAILING ADDRESS PHONE NUMBER
EMAIL OF THE SOURCE FOR ITEMS
CONTAINED IN THEIR REPORTS. WHEN
HIS VEHICLE HISTORY REPORTS
CONTAIN INCORRECT. YOU CAN
QUICKLY THE VALUE OF VEHICLE
MAKING IT HARDER FOR NEW. FOR
CAR OWNER TO SELL THIS BILL MAKE
ERRORS EASIER TO FIX FOR
CONSUMERS THAT'S INCREASING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. THE LATEST
AMENDMENTS REMOVED OPPOSITION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
REMAINING OPPOSITION IN THE
SENATE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE AND ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WE
DESIRE TO VOTES.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
FIFTY FOUR I NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEMS. THIRTY SIX THREE TWO
FORTY FOUR THE SHELBY PASTOR'S
CHANGE WE WILL MOVE ON NOW FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA BACK IN SCHOOL
GOVERNMENT'S. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY TWO CODIFIES THE RECENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S LEGAL
OPINION. THAT AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OR EMPLOYEE OF A
CHARTER SCHOOL MAY NOT SERVE AS
A MEMBER OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN THE COUNTY WHERE
THEIR EMPLOYEES SCHOOL IS
LOCATED. EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS
AN EMPLOYEE OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FROM BEING AN ELECTED
OR APPOINTED MEMBER OF THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT'S GOVERNING
BOARD UNLESS AND UNTIL THEY
RESIGNED AS AN EMPLOYEE. AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO APPLIES THE
SAME LIMITATION TO ANY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OR CHARTER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE FROM SERVING ON THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AUTHORIZING
SCHOOL DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD
. WHILE PROVIDING A PROCESS THAT
PROCESS FOR THE IMPACTED SITTING
BOARD MEMBERS TO FINISH THEIR
RESPECTIVE TERMS OF OFFICE. THIS
BILL IS A SIMPLE SOLUTION TO
ENSURE FAIR AND DIVERSE
REPRESENTATION FOR PARENTS
TEACHERS AND OUR STUDENTS ON
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS. CHARTER
SCHOOLEXECUTIVES OR EMPLOYEES
SERVING ON EDUCATION BOARDS IN
THEIR SCHOOLS JURISDICTION IS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AND AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL PREVENT
ANY CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND
ESTABLISH EQUALITY. AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY TWO HAS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA SEEING
AND HEARING AT NO FURTHER
DEBATES AND ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE
TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES IS FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FORTY SIX THROUGH
FIFTY EIGHT SHALL BE PASSED IN
OR CHANGE. WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE AJ ARE
TWENTY SEVEN. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS ARIAN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME RESOLUTION TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS VERY WELL TO
TURN ASSYRIAN ANGRY GENOCIDE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NECESSARY IN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERICA THAT YOUR
DESK THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I
RISE TODAY I HAVE A REASON
PREVIOUS YEARS ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO PRESENT ON AJ ARE
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH MEMORIALIZES
THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE A
COMMEMORATIVE COMMEMORATIVE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
ASSYRIAN AND GREEK GENOCIDE.
CALLING JUST A FEW YEARS AGO-
EVEN THOUGH THIRTY FIVE NATIONS
HAVE- THE COLLEGE THE GENOCIDE
AND HAVE CONTRIBUTED IN MANY
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT THE TRIAL
SEEM ATROCITIES DO NOT HAPPEN
AGAIN AND FURTHER EDUCATION ON
THE ISSUE. OUR OWN VERY UNITED
STATES UP UNTIL LAST YEAR HAD
NOT RECOGNIZED THIS AS A THE
INCIDENTS WHAT HAPPENED
ARMENIANS ASSYRIANS AND GREEKS
AS A GENOCIDE. AND TO THE ROOT
OF THE WORD ITSELF GENOCIDE
ITSELF WAS COINED A TERM IN
ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE BASED ON
THE TWO LATIN WORDS WHAT IT
MEANS TO ACTUALLY TRY TO
ERADICATE THE WHOLE NATION OR A
TRIBE OF PEOPLE. BECAUSE IT'S
GENERAL C. THE GETTING RID OF
THE WHOLE NEED PEOPLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE- AND THIS WORD ITSELF
APPROPRIATELY WAS COINED BY
RAPHAEL LEMKIN WHO WHOSE FAMILY.
AT HE HIMSELF HAD SUFFERED AT
THE ATROCITIES OF HITLER AND SO
HE- HAD COINED THIS TERM GIVEN
THE STUDIES HE HAD CONDUCTED TED
COME TO A CONCLUSION OF WHAT.
GENOCIDE MEANS AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO ERADICATE A WHOLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE BASED ON EITHER. THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN THEIR
RELIGION WHO THEY ARE OR WHAT
CULTURES THEY COME FROM.
COLLEAGUES LAST YEAR PRESIDENT
BIDEN BECAME THE FIRST PRESIDENT
. IN A STATEMENT TO RECOGNIZED
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AS A
GENOCIDE. BEFORE AN OCCURRENCE
THAT CLAIMED THE LIVES OF THREE
MILLION VICTIMS. INCLUDING THE
SYRIANS GREEKS AND OTHER
MINORITY GROUPS. IT'S TAKEN US
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS TO GIVE
THIS TO WAIT. BUT EVEN THEN IT
COMES WITH THE DENIAL BY THE
PERPETRATORS THEMSELVES. AND WE
COULDN'T SEE THIS MORE CLEARLY
THAN WHAT HAPPENED TWO YEARS AGO
. WHEN THE NEIGHBORING COUNTRY
OF ARMENIA AZERBAIJAN FUELED BY
. ITS NEIGHBOR AND BENEFITS SURE
OF ITS OIL WEALTH. TO THE WEST
TURKEY REPUBLIC OF TURKEY.
CONTINUE TO CARRY OUT YET
ANOTHER ATROCIOUS ATTACK WHILE
THE WORLD WAS IN THE SLUMBER OF
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC. AND WHEN
OUR COUNTRY HAD A PRESIDENT
THAT. MAYBE THEY FELT COULD TURN
A BLIND EYE. OF DURING THESE
ONGOING AND SO UNFORTUNATELY.
BECAUSE THE GENOCIDE ITSELF WAS
NOT. UNEQUIVOCALLY STATED AND
SPOKEN ABOUT BY THE UNITED
STATES. WE SAW A HUNDRED YEARS
LATER OVER A HUNDRED YEARS LATER
THEIR BE ANOTHER ATTACK ON THE
SMALL COUNTRY OF ARMENIA AS AS
THOUGH TO ERADICATE THE
REMAINING VESTIGES THAT WEREN'T
GOTTEN RID OF BEFORE AND THIS
HAPPENED BEFORE ALL OF US. SO
EVEN WITH MODERN TECHNOLOGY EVEN
WITH. THE AMPLE INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE EVEN WITH THE CLICK OF A
BUTTON HOW QUICKLY INFORMATION
GETS DISSEMINATED. IT'S HARD TO.
I THINK THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
COULD HAPPEN WHEN WE KNOW SO
MUCH ABOUT IT. BUT IT DID. IT
HAPPENED RIGHT BEFORE US. AND
THAT IN ITSELF IS THE REASON WHY
WE NEED TO ALWAYS REMEMBER
ALWAYS SPEAK OUT ALWAYS EDUCATE
AND ALWAYS TELL OUR CHILDREN.
WHAT DEBT AND THAT INCIDENT
MEANS BECAUSE OF THREE
GENERATIONS REMOVED. I'M STILL
IMPACTED BY IT. I RAN FOR OFFICE
AND GOT INVOLVED IN POLITICS
BECAUSE OF THE DEEP. DEEPLY HELD
SENSE OF INJUSTICE THAT'S
OCCURRED I KNOW MANY OF US.
BRING THAT RICHNESS OF THAT
IMPACT WITH ALL OF US WHETHER
YOU'RE FROM CENTRAL AMERICA
WHETHER YOU'RE AFRICAN AMERICAN
WHETHER YOU'RE JEWISH DOESN'T
MATTER WHETHER YOU'RE IRISH YOU
HAVE BEEN LEAD HERE BECAUSE OF A
CERTAIN SENSE OF OBLIGATION
BURDEN BY THE HISTORY OF YOUR
PEOPLE. AND YOU WANNA FIX THAT.
YOU WANT TO CORRECT SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN WRONG CONTINUES TO
BE WRONG. SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO BE WORKING
WITH MANY OF YOU OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST NOW ALMOST AT THE
END BY THE END OF THE YEAR. THIS
DECADE. TO BRING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD. I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO.
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE. REGARDLESS
OF WHO'S STANDING HERE BECAUSE
IF WE KNOW EACH OTHER'S PLIGHT
IF OUR ALL OF OUR COMMON
DENOMINATOR IS THE TRAUMA. THAT
MAKES US BETTER AS INDIVIDUALS
AND MAKES OUR SOCIETY THAT WE
GOVERN BETTER. THEN IT IS
IRRELEVANT WHO IT IMPACTED. ALL
IT MAY IS THAT HUMANITY WAS SET
ASIDE. THEY KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S NEVER ACCEPTED
BY ANY OF US BECAUSE IF IT IS.
THEN WE'RE DOOMED TO CONTINUE
REPEATING IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE G. R. TWENTY SEVEN I WANT
TO FIRST OF ALL I THANK THE
MEMBER FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR BEING A LEADER IN
THIS ISSUE FOR MANY MANY YEARS
AND FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
RESOLUTION. I WANT TO TELL YOU
ALL AS A THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE LARGEST COMMUNITY OF
DIASPORA ARMENIANS- IN THE WORLD
HOW IMPORTANT THIS RESOLUTION IS
FOR MY COMMUNITY- EVERY YEAR THE
ENTIRE CITY OF GLENDALE AND IN
FACT THE REGION COMES TOGETHER
LIKE AT NO OTHER TIME. ON APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO ALL THE
RESIDENTS OF MY CITY WHETHER
THEY'RE OF ARMENIAN DESCENT OR
NOT AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT THE
GENOCIDE RECOGNITION THAT OUR
CITY HOLDS EVERY YEAR HAS DONE
SO MUCH TO EDUCATE THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE TRAUMA. AND ABOUT THE-
THE HISTORY OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND I FEEL THAT BRINGING
RESOLUTION TO THE CAPITAL EVERY
YEAR HAS DONE THE SAME THING.
ROSS THE STATE OF. AND THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT STILL
FEELS THAT TRAUMA TODAY AND NOT
JUST BECAUSE OF HAVING LOST
FAMILY MEMBERS AND ANCESTORS AND
NOT JUST BECAUSE THE WOUNDS THAT
THEY HOLD PSYCHICALLY COULD
NEVER CLOSE UNTIL THERE'S FULL
WORLDWIDE RECOGNITION THAT THOSE
EVENTS WERE INDEED A GENOCIDE
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE MORE
RECENT EVENTS REFERENCED BY MY
COLLEAGUE. OF THE INVASION OF
ARMENIA. AND ARTSAKH BY ITS
NEIGHBORS AND THE CONTINUED
AGGRESSION THE CONTINUED
VIOLENCE AND BLOODSHED. THE
COMMUNITY FEELS THAT THE
GENOCIDE THAT BEGAN IN. NINETEEN
FIFTEEN. PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER
TRULY WASHED THE ARMENIAN BLOOD
OFF THEIR HANDS AT THOSE SAME
PEOPLE ARE CONTINUING ACTS OF
AGGRESSION MEANT. TO WIPE
ARMENIA OFF THE MAP. AND I WILL
SAY THAT IT'S MY HOPE THAT AS
CALIFORNIA WE RAISE OUR VOICES
TO SAY THAT WE WILL NOT ON OUR
WATCH ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN. WITH
THAT I URGE AN AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK- YOU GO MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BROTHERS AND
SISTERS OF COURSE I SUPPORT A.
J. R. TWENTY SEVEN WITH MY VERY
GOOD FRIEND. NOW I HAVE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THIS OF COURSE
. I MOURN AND THINK OF THE
ARMENIANS IN. NINETEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. FOR THEIR LOSSES BUT I
WOULD REMIND THIS LEGISLATURE
THAT. GENOCIDE IS STILL ALIVE
AND WELL IN THE WORLD. I'VE
WITNESSED IT I'VE SEEN. QUIET
SLAUGHTER KNOW WHAT I MEAN BY
QUIET SLAUGHTER IS IF YOU WANNA
PERPETRATE REAL GOOD GENOCIDE
YOU CUT OFF THEIR FOOD SUPPLY.
GENOCIDE TODAY IS STARVATION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MR VOEPEL THIS FELLOW THAT
IS YOUR RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF A AJ ARE TWENTY SEVEN. THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH AS THE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. THIS
HORRIBLE TRAGEDY IS STILL TOO
OFTEN DENIED AS A HISTORICAL
FACT BY INDIVIDUALS AND
GOVERNMENTS TO ILLUSTRATE HOW
REAL THIS ABOUTWAS I'D LIKE TO
SHARE THE STORY OF DOROTHY
PALLADIAN. DOROTHY WAS JUST A
LITTLE GIRL IN THE EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY LIVING IN
ARMENIA WHEN SHE HEARD A KNOCK
AT THE DOOR. HER PARENTS WERE
TOLD TO PACK UP THEIR BELONGINGS
AND TO TAKE ONLY WHAT THEY COULD
CARRY. THERE ARE BEING RELOCATED
BY THE OTTOMAN TURKS AT THE
START OF WORLD WAR ONE. THEIR
JOURNEY WAS HORRIFIC. ONE DAY
DURING THE MARCH OF THE
RELOCATION ALL OF THE MEN
INCLUDING DOROTHY'S FATHER WERE
TOLD TO START DIGGING AT THE
BASE OF THE HILL. LITTLE DID
THEY KNOW. THAT THEY WERE
DIGGING THEIR OWN GRAVES. THAT
DAY THE MAN AND DOROTHY'S
CARAVAN WERE SHOT. DOROTHY NEVER
SAW HER FATHER AGAIN. THE WOMEN
AND CHILDREN CONTINUED ON THE
JOURNEY WITNESSING MANY
ATROCITIES AND DURING
UNSPEAKABLE HARDSHIPS. RACKERS
FLEE THROUGH THE EFFORTS OF A
RIGHTEOUS AND MORAL TURK DOROTHY
HER SIBLINGS AND HER MOTHER
ESCAPED BEING PART OF ONE AND A
HALF MILLION ARMENIANS WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES IN THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN. AT
OF DEVASTATION A MASSACRE
MASSACRE CAME FREEDOM IN A NEW
COUNTRY A NEW LAND A PLACE TO
WORSHIP AND BE FREE WERE DOROTHY
ARRIVED TO ELLIS ISLAND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WITH HER MY
MOTHER AND YOUNGEST BROTHER BY
HER SIDE. IN NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THE FAMILY HER OLDER AND
HER OLDER BROTHERS JOINING THEM
AND THE FAMILY WAS REUNITED IN
AMERICA. THE COUNTRY THE OFFERED
THEM FREEDOM AND NOW BECAME
THEIR HOME. I AM HONORED TO
SHARE THE BILLION FAMILY STORY
WHICH IS ALSO THE STORY OF MY
FRIEND AND SCHEDULER CRISTINA
PAXTON. TODAY WE RECOGNIZE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ARMENIANS WHO
WERE SLAUGHTERED DURING WORLD
WAR TWO. I AM PROUD THAT MY
DISTRICT IS HOME TO MANY
ARMENIANS THEY ARE RESILIENT AND
STRONG PEOPLE WHO CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR CULTURE AND OUR ECONOMY. AND
THEIR STRONG THROUGH THEIR
STRONG WORK ETHIC. WHAT WE
COMMEMORATE A DARK AND DREADFUL
TIME IN THEIR HISTORY I'M PROUD
ARMENIANS CHOSE THIS COUNTRY.
OUR COUNTRY TO RAISE THEIR
FAMILIES CONTINUE THEIR
TRADITIONS AND TO BE FREE I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON HR
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU WITH ALL
OF THAT IS MR PATTERSON YOU
RECOGNIZE TO DESK. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE
ALSO TO JOIN IN THE CHORUS OF
THOSE SUPPORTING. OF THIS
RESOLUTION. AND WE HAVE HEARD
THE STORIES OF THE PAIN AND THE
SUFFERING. A AND THE LONG LONG
JOURNEY. FOR RECOGNITION. SO
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS CAN BE
RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT IT WAS. I
COME FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WHICH- HAS A
WONDERFUL A COMMUNITY. OF
ARMENIANS. AND YES THERE IS THE
BITTERNESS. WHAT HAPPENED. TO SO
MANY OF MY FRIENDS FAMILIES.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS CARNAGE.
AND YET I WANT TO RISE IN.
RECOGNITION OTHER RESILIENCY OF
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE DESPITE THE
EFFORT TO WIPE THEM OUT. THEY
FOUND FAITH I FOUND FREEDOM THEY
FOUND HOPE THEY FOUND NEW LIVES
AND THEY HAVE BEEN A RICH
ADDITION. TO THE WONDERFUL
TAPESTRY THAT IS FRESNO IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. SO WHILE
THIS IS BETTER IN REMEMBRANCE OF
THE CARNAGE. MEMBERS IT CAN BE
SWEET IN RECOGNITION OF THE
LIVES ARMENIANS LIVE AMONGST US
TODAY. AND THEY LIVE OUT THE
LEGACY. AFTER FAITH AND OF THEIR
DREAM AND- BOB BEING OUR
NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS. IT IS
TODAY. TESTAMENT TO THE ARMENIAN
VIRTUES AND THEIR STRENGTH. THAT
FRESNO WAS ONCE A PLACE. IT SAID
IN THERE. DOCUMENTS OF PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP. BUT THEY WOULD NOT
SELL TO AN ARMENIAN. AND YET
TODAY. THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IS
A LEADERSHIP COMMUNITY EDUCATION
IN FINANCE AND AGRICULTURE YES
AND A WHOLE LOT OF LAND
OWNERSHIP A LOT HAS HAPPENED
SINCE THE HORROR. AND WE ARE
CELEBRATING. WHAT HAS BECOME
TODAY. THOSE WHO LIVE AMONGST US
. GIVE US HOPE. BUT SHOW US THAT
THE AMERICAN DREAM IS SO REAL.
YOU KNOW MY FAMILY SCOTCH IRISH
ENGLISH AND IT PUTS BACK QUITE A
LONG TIME AGO. MY ARMENIAN
FRIENDS. AT THE VOICE IN MY EAR
. WHAT THEIR RECORD IS LIKE.
WHEN PEOPLE FOR FREE AND WHO ARE
. PERSECUTED. AND THEN THEY FIND
REFUGE. AND THEN THEYHAVE
FAMILY GROSS. AND THEN THEY
BECOME SIX ASK. FOR AND MANY
BECOME WEALTHY AND THEY SHARED
THEIR GOODNESS. WITH OTHERS
THAT'S THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY
THAT I LIVE AMONGST. AND SO
TODAY IT'S BETTER. BUT IT'S ALSO
SWEET. BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE OUR
BELOVED IN OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND THEY STAND
UPON THE SHOULDERS OF THE
SUFFERERS AND A MORE. BUT THEY
ALSO STAND TALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR PATTERSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MADAMS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SPOKEN. AS A CLOSE I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ASK ALL OF US TO STAND
AND FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR
A MINUTE AND THIRTY SECONDS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN FOR
LEADING US IN THAT MISTER
NAZARIAN WOULD YOU LIKE THE
FIRST ROLL CALL TO BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS. YES PLEASE. ALL THE
BAY HAVING CEASED THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE FOR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY TWO CO AUTHORS
ADDED. MOVING ON NOW TO OF VOTE
ON THE MEASURE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTE- DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSER ALL. THERE ARE SIXTY
FOUR I KNOW ZERO. THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM SIXTY H. R. EIGHTY
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
THE CLERK WILL READ. HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVEN
THIS YEAR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE TODAY. H.
R. EIGHTY ONE IS A LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS RESOLUTION
COMMEMORATING APRIL AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT AWARENESS MONTH IN APRIL
TWENTY SEVENTH AS DENIM DAY TO
THAT END THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCS ENCOURAGES ALL MEMBERS
AND STAFF TO WEAR DOWN AND THIS
WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH.
EVEN TOUGH WE TAKE UP THIS
RESOLUTION EVERY YEAR I- JUST
NOT TREAT BOTH SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH AND DENIM DAY AS
ROUTINE. AS A STATE THERE IS
STILL SO MUCH WORK FOR US TO DO
TO COMBAT SEXUAL ASSAULT APE
TRAUMA AND SURVIVOR CENTERED
POLICIES AND CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE SURVIVORS FEEL
EMPOWERED TO STEP FORWARD AND
REPORT WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM. AS
WE ALL KNOW THE GENESIS A DENIM
DAY IS A NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
ITALIAN SUPREME COURT CASE THAT
OVERTURNED A RAPE CONVICTION
BECAUSE A SURVIVOR WAS WARY
JEANS WHEN SHE WAS ASSAULTED.
SIMPLY PUT THE POINT OF HR
EIGHTY ONE IS THAT THERE IS
NEVER EVER ANY EXCUSE FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT. FULL STOP ZERO FOR TOO
LONG OUR CULTURE HAS BEEN ONE
THAT PROTECTS PERPETRATORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT PRESERVES
OUTDATED NOTIONS OF PATRIARCHY
DISCOURAGES SURVIVORS FROM
STEPPING FORWARD AND WE KNOW
THAT FOR EVERY ONE THOUSAND
SURVIVORS IN THE UNITED STATES
ONLY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY REPORT
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT PERPETRATED
AGAINST ON AN OUT OF TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SURVIVORS ONLY EIGHTY
HOW CRIMINAL CASES GO TO TRIAL.
AND LESS THAN FIVE WILL EVER SEE
THE PERPETRATORS. ANY TIME IN
JAIL OR PRISON. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT UNFORTUNATELY SEXUAL
ASSAULT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY. WE
CAN DO BETTER WE MUST DO BETTER
AND WE WILL DO BETTER. I AM
PROUD THIS YEAR LAST YEAR THIS
HOUSE WORK TOGETHER TO PASS MY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE NINE
WHICH FINALLY CLOSE THE DENIM
DAY LOOPHOLE ALLOWING SURVIVORS
CLOTHING TO BE USED AGAINST THEM
AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT. LOOPHOLE
THAT HAD ONE EXISTED IN OUR
STATE LAWS THE FACT THAT THIS
LOOPHOLE HAD BEEN SITTING IN OUR
STATUTES FOR ALL THESE YEARS AS
WE TOOK UP RESOLUTIONS LIKE THE
ONE TODAY TALKING. ABOUT EVERY
YEAR HOW THE IMPORTANCE OF.
COMMEMORATING DAY IS A TELLING
INDICATOR THAT WE STILL HAVE SO
MUCH WORK TO DO IN OUR OWN STATE
. SO TODAY COLLEAGUES I STAND
HERE TO ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
DOUBLING DOWN ON OUR COMMITMENT
AS MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE TO
ENSURE THAT THE FORCIBLE WORDS
IN THIS RESOLUTION DID NOT
REMAIN JUST WORDS ON A PIECE OF
PAPER. WE MUST MAKE ACTIONS OUT
OF THESE WORDS AND USE THE LAW
MAKING PRIVILEGE WE HAVE AS
MEMBERS OF THIS ASSEMBLY BODY TO
COMBAT THE SPECTER OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT IN OUR SOCIETY. AS A
RESOLUTION NOTES THERE ARE OVER
TWO TWENTY TWO MILLION TWENTY
TWO MILLION SURVIVORS. OF
ASSAULT IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
RAPE CRISIS CENTERS PROVIDED
SERVICES TO OVER FORTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. THOSE NUMBERS ARE
STILL FAR TOO MANY. UNTIL THEY
MET MEMBERS OF NEW SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS PER YEAR
REACHES ZERO. WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO. FOR THOSE REASONS
COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOU TO
STAND WITH ME. AND SUPPORT AND
BOEING HI. BUT H. R. EIGHTY. AND
I ASK THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
COOPER'S. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAID ABOUT THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF YOUR CAREER
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK MADAM
SPEAKER IN COLLEAGUES TODAY
ARISE ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
EIGHTY ONE DENIM DAY. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAVANT
IS FOR CONTINUOUSLY ADVOCATING
THAT CLOSE NEVER EVER PROVIDE
CONSENT. THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
VICTIMS BEHAVIOR THAT CAN EXCUSE
A PROPERTY PERPETRATORS ACTION.
TODAY WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY DO
YOU WITH SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS THEY REMIND EVERYONE
THAT NOTHING EXCUSES SEXUAL
ASSAULT. NOTHING NOTHING AT ALL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I GET CURRY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SERVE ON THIS AT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I ASKED FOR
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
ABOUT THIS IS US AT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTES. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE. THERE ARE SIXTY
SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY NO. THE
EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
ABOUT THIS. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE THROUGH SIXTY
FIVE. FOR LIVING ON THE FILE
FOUR. V. A. THOSE MEASURES ARE
PASSED RETAINED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THIS THIS SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA TO ALLOW THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO MEET FOR THEIR
HEARING THIRTY MINUTES EARLY AT
ONE PM ON TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY
SIX AT TEN TWENTY ONE- STREET IN
ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER MOVING ON TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE ANY ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE SIXTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND OTHERS AND I RELATE TO
INVIOLABILITY. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
WHICH YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLAND TALLY
THE VOTES. I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
. MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT
TWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SIX BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FIVE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY WILL MEET AT TWO
THIRTY IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT TWO
THIRTY IN ROOM FOR FORTY FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT TWO THIRTY PM AND ROOM
FOR FORTY SEVEN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT TWO THIRTY PM IN SWING
SPACE ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED AND
THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT THREE
THIRTY AND FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. IN
THE ABSENCE OF AN OBJECTION
MOVING ON TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY OF THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. OKAY MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I AM ASKING-
THIS BODY TO ADJOURN. IN THE.
RECOGNITION OF ONE OF THE GREAT
QUARTERBACKS IN. NFL HISTORY
PLEASE JOIN ME IN REMEMBERING
THE LIFE AND THE LEGACY OF
FORMER RAIDERS QUARTERBACK AND
CLOVIS NATIVE DARYL LAMONICA WHO
PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK AT EIGHTY
YEARS OF AGE. BERYL LED THE
RAIDERS TO THEIR FIRST SUPER
BOWL APPEARANCE AND FOR BACK TO
BACK DIVISION TITLES BETWEEN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN. AND
NINETEEN SEVENTY. DARYL WAS
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AND
FEARFULLY KNOWN. AS THE MAD
BOMBER. FOR THE DEEP PASSES HE
WAS SO GOOD AT THROWING AND
COMPLETING. HE WAS NAMED THE ALL
AFL MVP IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AND IS STILL THE THIRD LEADING
PASSER OF ANY RAIDERS PLAYER. AT
ONE POINT HE HELD THE RECORD FOR
MOST PASSES ATTEMPTED MOST
COMPLETIONS TOTAL YARDS AND
TOUCHDOWN PASSES FOR THE RAIDERS
. WE REMEMBER DARRYL MONICA AS A
NATIVE. SON AND A FRIEND AND ONE
WHO LIVED AMONGST US. AND GAVE
BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY IN
SUBSTANTIAL WAYS UPON HIS
RETIREMENT. BERYL WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN FRESNO HE ATTENDED
CLOVIS HIGH SCHOOL BEFORE
ATTENDING NOTRE DAME. TODAY THE
FOOTBALL STADIUM AND IT'S A
MAGNIFICENT STADIUM WORTHY OF
HIS MEMORY AT CLOVIS HIGH
PROUDLY BEARS HIS NAME. LAMONICA
STADIUM. THERE WAS A BIG PART OF
RAIDER NATION BUT AS I MENTIONED
HE WAS ALSO A GREAT ICON BACK AT
HOME. THE CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SAID I'M QUOTING HIS
LEGACY IS ONE THAT LIVES ON NOT
ONLY THROUGH THE BELOVED STADIUM
THAT BEARS HIS NAME BUT IN THE
COACHES. MR MATH LEADS AND THE
FANS WHO ARE PART OF THE CLOVIS
UNIFIED ATHLETIC TRADITION. SO
OUR THOUGHTS OUR PRAYERS OUR
CONDOLENCES ARE WITH HIS FAMILY
WITH HIS WIFE MARY. AND SON
BRANDON AS THEY MOURN HIS LOSS.
BUT ALSO WE ARE RECOLLECTING
FONDLY. THE ENJOYMENT ALL. BUT
ONE WONDERFUL WAY THAT HE PLAYED
. FOOTBALL NOT RECOLLECTION IS
FILLED. WITH THE EXPLOITS OF THE
MAD BOMBER SO ALTHOUGH WE ARE
SAD IN LOSING HIM. WE ARE
GRATEFUL IN RECOGNIZING HIM FOR
WHAT HE DID IN OUR MIDST BOTH ON
THE FIELD AND OFF AND WE
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE. THAT WAS
VERY WELL LIVED I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
GERALD MONICA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR PATTERSON YOU'RE CALLING
FROM OAKLAND ALSO THINKS YOU.
FOR THAT ADJOURNMENTS MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THEN NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MOVING ON TO THE SESSION
SCHEDULE WHICH IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY SIX WE WILL
HAVE A CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH
ALSO CHECK IN SESSION. THURSDAY
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
AND RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS WALDRON- MOVES AND MISS
GARCIA SECONDS THAT THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH AT NINE AM.